Buenas tardes Dominic es el tercer
funcionario de alto nivel ministro que
tiene que salir del gobierno desde que
Richie sunat es Primer Ministro hace
apenas seis meses en el caso de rap como
ya nos contabas había acusaciones de
bullying laboral una posición humillante
frente a los empleados y abuso de poder
por ello el Primer Ministro Richie sunat
encargó a una de las empresas de
abogados top del Reino Unido para que se
encargara de esta investigación formal e
independiente y esclareciera esas
conductas y esas denuncias de por lo
menos ocho empleados que han trabajado
con rap en diferentes carteras como
Ministerio de Justicia y también
Ministerio de exteriores como lo
recordabas encontró que sí había fallos
y que rap tenía una conducta agresiva
hacia los empleados la salida por
supuesto de rap hace apenas unas horas
Pese a que el gobierno recibió el
informe ayer pone en una posición de
debilidad política a Richie sunat porque
ha perdido hoy nuevamente a un nuevo de
sus grandes aliados y amigos políticos
pero también hacen que el público en
general se pregunte si el Primer
Ministro está eligiendo a las personas
idóneas para los altos cargos del estado